[thud]
Greetings, brothers.
Forgive our surprise.
We're expecting to see some
of our own Templar brothers.
Of course.
And what brings
you so far from--
Hautville.
That's quite a distance.
There's been
rumor of a Templar
frequenting this convent
engaging in unspeakable acts.
What unspeakable acts?
[music playing]
MAN 1: Identify yourselves.
If neither of you are
the Templar I speak of,
you have nothing to fear.
MAN 2: My name is
Tancrede de Hautville.
MAN 3: I'm Landry du Lauzon.
[music playing]
MAN 1: Brother,
why would you draw
your sword on a fellow Templar?
Because I know that horse.
And because Templars carry
swords, not cross bows.
[music playing]
And because you
are not Templars.
Kill them!
[grunting]
MAN 3: Inside!
Get yourself to safety.
Tell the rest of your sisters.
Find a room, lock the door.
Let's go.
WOMAN: I'm not leaving.
MAN 2: There's no time, Anne.
Tancrede, this is my home.
Dangerous men
impersonating Templars--
- We have to go.
- --are here.
Come on.
We have to leave, Anne.
Anne, please.
[music playing]
Come on.
All right.
[music playing]
Get the horses.
Take the roads to Chartres.
We'll be right behind you.
[loud bang]
[music playing]
Go.
[loud bang]
[music playing]
[grunting]
We're going to kill
you and then your baby.
[grunting]
WOMAN: Hurry.
Hurry up.
[panting]
MAN 4: Who are you?
I've done nothing to you.
Oh, but you have, Landry.
[grunting]
[yelling]
MAN 5: Prince Louis.
MAN 1: They're getting
away with the baby!
Gaylord, kill the Templar!
[grunting]
Go, go, go, go!
[grunt]
[grunting]
MAN 2: Landry, we have to go.
[grunts]
Landry, come on.
[music playing]
[groans]